and we're live good to be here all right
yeah wow what a conundrum we just set it
all up and we're here at the firehouse
hostel
where derek lives just chatting up a
storm
yeah i'm derek dimpful hans kim what is
your podcast called
uh it doesn't really have a name it's
just more like
uh doing it to do it it's like
practicing podcasting
but actually podcasting so okay i don't
think the name's that important maybe
if i get famous people will go back to
this and listen to it
okay but the but the idea right now is
just to
get accustomed to a studio conversation
setting
it's to talk to people that i want to
talk to
and i'm currently doing it okay so it's
happening
all right it's just pretty cool that you
can just start doing it because back in
the day if you wanted to do a radio show
you'd have to
write go book a studio but now you can
just do it like this
right yeah so do you publish it on
anchor
no just youtube facebook okay cool yeah
yeah what's anchor uh it's a podcast
publishing
platform which you can share it to
spotify
itunes etc it's totally free
um that's where i i published my podcast
it's audio only though but
but anchor does support video does it uh
cost money
no no anchor yeah it's anchor.fm is
totally free
well it's now going to be on anchor.fm
check us out all right
so what do you think about america what
do i think about america
um all right well i'll try to
leave behind because there are so many
there's so many layers to that question
right
um so what i'm wanting to do right now
is
shuffle off my stereotypes and kind of
get to the bottom level
well i'd say that
coming from massachusetts originally
i learned to have a very positive
attitude
towards america because massachusetts
bay colony outside of
um outside of jamestown virginia was the
first colony
you know in america and so there's a lot
of pride over that kind of thing um
and
and like in one of the major holidays in
my hometown concord is patriots day when
we
chased away the british you know in the
battles of lexington
and concord and so forth yeah so
that was a really big part of my
upbringing
uh i'd say that i'm i'm positively
disposed towards america
because of the history and where you
grew up um well i'd say that that you
know that lays the foundation
for my attitude towards america yeah
yeah for sure
so because you're born here and you
grew you have a lot of connections to
here you like it
[Music]
not just because of that um
but i have a all right so so uh
so uh what are you getting at with a
question
like um you like america because
it's the land of your birth and you have
loyalty to it and
you know the history you grew up around
the history
but uh as opposed to like a general if
you're an
alien and you're observing each country
attributes
and that's hard to say like like to to
view things from like an
alien perspective but my
like the way that i'm disposed towards
america is not
purely a matter of loyalty as a matter
of fact i think it's a lot less a matter
of loyalty
than it is at least you know at least in
in my mind and my heart today and you've
caught me sort of on an off day like i
would say that
it's more it's more of like
a positive emotional connection to it
yeah
cause like those earliest years when i
was living in massachusetts were
were some of the like happier and
happiest years of my life and so when i
think about
so it's like i think that's it's
entangled with that
entangled yeah so it's a formative part
of your
growing up and your personage yeah um
yeah but i mean you know and of course i
learned the history of
i was taught to think of america as
exceptional as a result of its early
history and as a matter of fact i really
enjoy
uh reading uh reading things like the
founding documents just because of
just just because just because i like
how the language is structured
like the bible except a little bit newer
no i i would say it's different um
obviously yeah well like no
that the bible is a lot
different to to me particularly because
particularly because it's translated no
i i don't think i don't have
nearly the same kind of connection
to those scripts yeah yeah
so why are you a little down right now
what what caused the downness
yeah uh well it's just uh the the the
last couple days like i think i
i think yeah i think i burnt through my
and i think i
just burnt through my energy reserves
and then wound up
um yeah and it just has just been a
little bit exhausted
and needed to recover so that one day
that
we hung out at kiko's and then
you slept at ridge's hostel bed
right well that that was yeah i mean
that that was part of it for sure like
i'm not accustomed to staying up until
five or six
um but it was it was still it's still in
total i think a fun night
um but but i think also part of it was
you know
bouncing from place to place like i
stayed two days with gareth that was
really nice of him to open up his house
and then
you know and then there was that like
big day that happened
and went to ihop at 5am
yeah that was fun and i definitely did
not expect all that and then i
stayed with ridge then i hoofed it over
here
and uh and so so
you walked all the way here from rich's
house no no no um
uh ridge gave me a ride but but by by
that i just mean like it was just
another day of traveling changing places
so just like three different places
in in three nights meant that i think i
was just a little bit exhausted so it's
just a
energy thing physically you're exhausted
there's no sort of emotional trauma that
happened
no no emotional trauma that occurred
that's that's such a this is a strong
word it's so overused these days
the word trauma is really yeah snuck in
especially amongst you know
millennials in our peer group is like oh
everything is traumatizing now
yeah some things are just events they
don't have to right
enact an emotional scar yeah i mean even
like even extremely negative events
don't necessarily leave you traumatized
it all depends on
yeah how you're able to recover from it
yeah
but yeah do you think people are more
nurture in nature
oh boy another like question
uh honestly well i think okay i think
that they are both
much more profoundly than most people
give it
gives it credit for um i would say
that there i i think that there are
things encoded in our dna
which go which go beyond
merely physical expression and have to
do
with memory and experiential
like experiential matters um like for
instance
like when we were over at kiko's and
like i dangled the snake
right next to ridge or like the plastic
snake and like you know you know he had
doing that all night well no i did that
twice i did that twice
i was one to you no you did it to kiko
or
okay oh yeah to noe into ridge i think
yeah and like and they both jump because
like it's
because it's a shape that's imprinted
and like you've probably seen nature
yeah like those videos of yeah and i
would say it's like well
maybe maybe what nature is is what
nurture becomes
over generations of consistent
experience
so you think that it's the same side of
different side of the same coin yeah
maybe it's different
yeah yeah maybe it's different
expressions
of the same yeah of the same process
yeah
like the difference between short and
long-term memory or something like that
yeah yeah i don't know if there's a real
difference between nature and nurture i
think it's like
how your nurturing
enables you to enact your nature and
what part of your nature
is able to survive in this environment
ah that's another yeah that's a good
point
it's like what what did you come
pre-loaded with which is and isn't
consistent with
success in the given conditions
yeah yeah so you're doing
better now that you have a constant
place to stay
well i mean it's only been like a night
or two that i've been back at the hostel
but yeah i think i'll be i'll be
recovering my strength
yeah this one seems a lot more
professionally run
than the last one definitely that's
a relief yeah i mean yeah in terms of
like each one
had its advantages yeah like drifter
jacks definitely had
you know yeah definitely had like a a
freer like more social environment yeah
but this one yes is more structured and
i think conducive
to longer-term stability in life
yeah and restfulness yeah yeah there's
yeah
probably get more rest here than there
yeah did you go to city limits yesterday
i did not
yeah did you yeah no okay i only thought
about it later but uh
yeah i mean i'm glad you're in a place
where you can stay at long term
it's just interesting that there's so
many comedians in
the austin texas scene that are staying
in hostels ridge
uh others that i don't know if christina
jose and yeah and i'm not sure which
other comedians are staying here at the
firehouse at what tyler large was for
time okay i don't know if he is anymore
yeah but but ridge and christina like
what they have is i mean
it used to be a hostel but it's like a
month to month renting you know but it's
like a communal living situation
is it cheaper than rent uh well it's
like 600 a month
for for ridge's shared room uh
so that's sort of cheap yeah i think you
can find something especially since he
has a car
but uh what's good about the hostel is
that you can leave
pretty easily yeah and you can get it
pretty easily
yeah it's like in between a hotel and
whatever
exactly apartment yeah i don't know how
much longer i'm going to be able to stay
here if i'm not on staff though
because um because there's
a well there's an official 14
day per year limit just to staying here
but i i don't know if they will
you know i don't know if they'll keep
that like
yeah i don't know if they'll enforce
that yeah yeah
it's interesting a lot of people are
moving here this is the hot
scene and hostels are filling up right
people are wanting to try it out yeah i
mean well this is now the only hostel in
town now that drifter jack's closed
it's just the firehouse folks if you
come to austin yeah
so do you think that's an efficient use
of city resources don't you think it'd
be better if we had more
of these kind of places to accommodate
drifters
definitely yeah well okay no hang on so
so that okay so
so uh i wouldn't go so far
as to okay well talking about efficient
use of city resources like
that brings in like that brings in a
normative element of the conversation
and that's that's a question that's not
easily answerable like unless you have
the whole budget laid out in front of
you
however i would say that yes i think
it's i think it would be a good thing
if austin had more hostiles matter of
fact talking with the owner of the
previous hostel
drifter jax which is now closed uh he
was talking about how just a few years
ago
there were like seven or eight hostels
in austin
but as a result of the way the economy
is moving
it's a lot more like the hostile
business model is no longer profitable
enough to to stay in business in most
parts of the city
um so as a consequence there are fewer
like there are fewer establishments
available
for traveling people yeah which i think
hurts the city
i think if you have a city that has a
port that you can
port yourself into then you get more
transient people who
can help the city and its culture and
try it out
okay so you're thinking oh you're
thinking along the lines of
you're thinking along the lines of what
like little
like extra pieces of flavor that
mobile and like non-like non-established
people
offer to a place i think that's true
um at the same time like at the same
time i
understand how the
economic forces of industry
moving to austin in this way
would like would cause things to
to move in the direction they have and i
don't necessarily think that that's
wrong
well i don't know if it's a pristine
experiment
i think we're living in a society that
has wealth inequality
so there's less people who are transient
who have the money to be able to afford
hostels and the only people who do have
money are like
tesla and uh elon musk and they get to
sort of form the city
however they want because they have all
the resources and their
idea of the city is very uh not
conducive to actual humanity
and transient people that make the city
and the culture
okay yeah i see what you mean
it might be a little bit okay so i think
on the
level of who has lots of money
and has the opportunity to shape uh to
shape
like civic arrangement that's that's
probably true
that like big companies and and very
wealthy people
do have like that kind of mac do have
a lot of influence as a result of the
resources that they have
but uh i
don't know if it's true that there like
aren't
enough people who are transient and have
the resources
to stay at a hostel like i think that
there are enough people
who are traveling who would be able to
stay at a hostel well then why are they
shutting
down oh oh i think well i think that the
hostels are shutting down because
oh yeah okay so that was a
miscommunication earlier yeah that
they're shutting down because
the property that they have could be
more profitably employed in a different
business
not because there aren't people who
can and will stay at a hostel the other
hostel was
was totally full earlier it's just that
the alternatives that the owners of the
property have
of like who can set up shop in their in
their property
uh you know have have more op like have
have
better options like businesses that
would pay more because they'd be
bringing in more money
but just chasing profits doesn't make a
city better
i agree as a matter of fact like if if
say like
this hostel closed down you know closed
down next week
then yeah no i i yeah that would be
really sad to me
that i i agree profit itself
doesn't make a city better yeah and um
i i i guess it's like
supposed to like profit supposed to
mimic what's
best for the community or
the country or the city or the world and
just to have
uh chasing profits if we did that
everything would be
a condominium or uh
i don't know a cupcake shop or whatever
and i don't think that's a good world to
live in and i think
like what we think as prophets is just
the whims
of the billionaire class since they have
all the money
and if we just uh make way for
profits we're just doing making the
world however they want it
as opposed to how we all want it i think
that you overestimate the influence
of of the extremely rich
in terms of their ability to shape
culture
um like for instance
the last hostel was was right next to
the ut campus
so i had the opportunity to walk many
times up and down
where like different shops which are
targeted at college students were
and those shops reminded me a lot
of of the shops like for instance new
year
your cupcake shops your eyebrow
threading
like uh like a supply company yeah like
clothing store called misbehaving then
there's like a bank which is associated
with the university
like that all seemed you know in
chipotle
those were exactly the kind of
businesses that were right next door to
my university
and so like that clued me into realizing
that
that the culture like that that there's
that there's kind of like a monoculture
in each of the different subsections of
our society because like everyone wants
to feel like they're
like so you know samantha who's going to
ut
and trevor who's going to ucsb like
our friends and they keep in touch and
they're separated by all this distance
and they have a different experience
because they're going to different
universities but
actually their lives are similar enough
that they can still communicate that
yeah so so like i don't in like for
instance like that kind of thing
i don't think is a result of the actions
of the billionaire class
i think it's i think it's like more
complicated and subtle
ripples in society that govern that um
but and and like for instance like
austin becoming like a big center
for tech i don't think is just i don't
think it's just
the consequence of you know the
decisions of billionaires i think it's
that
like birds of a feather flock together
right and in the same way that san jose
got totally you know inundated with
people going there for tech jobs i think
is similar things happening in austin
but and then and then when it comes to
like okay so so they're making a certain
amount of money
so then what are like the rationally
like then just
what are the kinds of services that you
would need you know for for those
uh for those people well uh housing
you need offices and then you need you
know you need
uh food availability uh
because they're gonna be very busy and
because it's predominantly male like you
probably want strip clubs and
and things i know seriously okay yeah
so you think that it's more like who's
moving here and we all get a say in how
we make this
environment and it's actually the people
that want the same thing everywhere
that's the problem
oh i'm not seeing i'm not talking about
in terms of a problem
uh i'm saying that well it's not
necessarily like the people who are
demanding like these four things but i'm
saying
but what i'm saying is like it's the
economy just naturally
producing what the people want yeah
there's like yeah
naturally and artificially you know
because like every person who employs
like a piece of industry whether that
industry is this building that we're
sitting in
or money that they have like makes
decisions about it
um but you know what whatever of those
decisions
are like are our profitable ones
are decisions that survive and then but
what is profitable is only what the rich
want
or what they have the ability to spend
on because no one else has the money
hmm well i think we're stuck well okay
well
okay you and i don't have too much money
but i think that
we we each have we each have resources
that we're constantly employing uh
for like two
in order to make our lives both as
enjoyable
sustainable and even profitable as we
can
so like i might be going into a job
soon which like like
where i'd be on the phone for maybe four
hours
four hours a day but it's like 60 grand
a year
or something and like that to me is like
is an
excellent financial decision
in order to you know like in order to
support my other goals in life
yeah but what you can spend that sixty
thousand dollars on is all decided by
people who own gaap and walmart
and like the four people who own all the
pharmaceutical companies or whatever
true or you know or that or that money
can be used to bring about because i
don't like
particularly care too much for the
things that i can consume
like yeah but if a person doesn't have a
consumer mindset
then they can employ that money to
create something totally new and
bring and usher something different into
the world well if we could pool our
resources together we
might be able to make a difference in
the world but unfortunately americans
don't really
pool their resources together they're in
it for themselves
and we don't really have an ability to
fight back against the billionaire class
yeah i think that we might be a little
bit
less in it for ourselves than most of us
are just
distracted and tranquilized by the
billionaire class not necessarily by the
billionaire class but like
by all of the consumption and
who drives entertainment well it's you
know it's not
yeah um well i think well i mean i think
we're all
like we're all agreeing to it on some
level you know
like the fact that so many people spend
their evenings just watching netflix and
vegging out you know it's like
yeah we're all agreeing i mean do you
don't think that
the billionaire class is as big of a
deal as i think it is
um so how big of a deal do you think it
is
and in what terms i mean all the jobs
that comedians
and our friend group do is like
food around walk dogs like these are not
very
economically impactful jobs we're just
like picking up the scraps
from the billionaires they decide what
jobs are useful and how much benefits we
get
and uh which stores exist and how our
roads look and how i wonder
so so yeah i wonder like how much
influence
the billionaire class has on
like on you were talking about roads and
public transportation and things like
that
i mean i think that that's like it's
much more directly impacted by
uh i think it's much more directly
impacted by the voter
well haven't you seen what they did in
los angeles how gm
and whatever killed the electric cars
and street cars
and i do know that story like the
highways and all that
so i mean i think they do have an
influence on
the way our cities look and they want us
to all driving cars because that's
profitable
even though it's not better it's not the
most sustainable yeah
so that's what i was referring to but i
guess like not the minute details but i
mean
i mean i guess i uh i don't like uh
you know like having to be
uh pray to the the people with money and
if our society is designed around money
then the people with the money are to
have more power and they're going to use
that power to accrue more resources and
then they're going to
dominate the market and i think having
just profit be your motive is a
dead end and monopolizing
monopoly inducing sure i'm hearing all
that
and i think that some amount of that is
true and
all of it could be true but i
think that the attitude that you're
taking towards it
in some sense feels like a dead end to
me and you can
you can clarify for me whether whether
i'm onto something here
is that the attitude feels really
victimizing to me
rather than rather than focusing on
well what is it that i have an
opportunity to do
uh well yeah maybe if the fundamental
like if the first thought is what is it
that i can do
to do what i want to do with my life in
order to
like in order to bring about rather than
saying like rather than the first
thought being
i was like well these people have all
the power well it's
infuriating and it's i know that it's
like
not emotionally healthy but i don't
think that's
a healthy way to go is just to feel the
best emotions all the time
okay but it's but it's infuriating yeah
and uh
right and so yeah what why why is it
infuriating
because of what our generation has been
put through and how
we're [ __ ] and our lives are ruined
by this system and i think that a lot of
people want to be like well it's fine
everything's okay but that's how it
continues
right it's infuriating because a whole
generation of people
have been have been offered poorer
choices
in the present than past generations
have been as a result
of the course that industry has taken
now
what i'm curious to hear from you is
like
uh okay we said it's infuriating and
that
solutions no no actually what actually
what what i'm what i'm curious about is
something like uh
like is is something a lot more personal
like
how like how that makes you feel
it makes me feel like we gotta burn it
all down and start over in sweden
okay i mean well why not just move to
sweden then
uh because i'm not from there i don't
speak the language
don't understand their culture i'm a
creature made for this
country and i feel like i'm best served
taking down america and it fills me with
so much
purpose and drive to be mad at
the world okay yeah i mean i think anger
is an excellent
motivating force when it has purpose
behind it and a goal
attached to it um
yeah but there's there's another
question i want to ask because
once once we once we touched on the fact
that you're infuriated
like a lot opened up for me because i
feel like
we can have a conversation because
um because it has to do with like
because it has to do
with more than what you're thinking but
also what you're feeling
mm-hmm but i don't know about like
feelings i just think that uh it's
easier to just be like oh this guy's
sort of gross let me
whatever he says must be wrong which i
don't know
i think it's better to take people's
logical statements and analyze them
rather than
they're emotional but true
well i mean or rather to say um
why i think they're both important yeah
but i guess uh i'm not as good at uh
emotional emotionally keeping up
emotional stamina or like emotional
health or emotional awareness
um but i mean so what do you think that
uh
the future of america looks like
i don't i don't know like um
it's very it's very uncertain to me
and i don't know speculations
speculation is really risky oh yeah
here's here's here's one other place
that i wanted to go to
this reminded me of it because like i
don't have like i don't think that i
have a broad enough personal experience
or a wide enough personal lens
in order to accurately prognosticate
what is going to go on in the future in
a
like in a macroscopic level yeah for
for america but something that i'm
curious to
know from you is like okay so you but
you talk about the billionaire class a
lot
like what kind of personal experience do
you
have with individuals who are members of
that
zero okay i don't have to personally
know them to
look at the numbers and look at our
lives and be like oh
they're taking it all okay and
okay so okay so you don't have any
personal experience
uh but okay but where you went with that
is
numbers so what would you say
the top like the the most impactful
things that you've heard
felt and experienced concerning that
topic have been for you
the job market uh
my friends were having to work server
jobs
and basically just like uh be their
servants and
wash their feet metaphorically
just like what we have to do to survive
and how much of our time we have to give
up
well when you talk about these things it
almost seems like there's a really like
there's a strong dichotomy in your mind
between and i might be wrong correct me
if i am between
people who are in like a service role
and those who are served in society
because like someone who i would serve
at a restaurant if i got a waiting job
today
most of those people aren't even close
to billionaires like
they're just there like getting
paychecks from billionaires
and then they use it on the service
industry and so like
in well okay so so yeah they they so
they serve
they serve some organization that they
work for
and exchange they have money which they
sometimes
employ in a capacity where others serve
them whether it's drinks or food or
kayaks or whatever um and
i you know and i am in
and i have some arrangements in my life
where i serve others whether it's
the the dry cleaning company or or
whatever and
there are some situations where like
where i'm served by other people
whether it's like someone like someone
might want to buy me a drink
like in a like in a social setting or
others also they serve me with their
attention when i'm like when i'm
performing for them on stage
yeah so i mean we can't have an economy
based on serving each other we actually
have to make something and where does
all that wealth come from and i think it
comes from third world countries
that we're exploiting because that's
america's
game that's the only thing we know how
to do yeah well okay
but you were saying we can't so there
are two things there we can't have an
economy which is based on serving each
other i would argue we can maybe we need
to approach serving each other
differently but i think like serving
each other is actually very
a very noble thing like i just think
that
if we're going to compete we can't just
be
maintaining okay although that would be
nice yeah and you're talking about
exploiting third world countries i would
say
much more generally that a lot of
economic growth comes as a result of
exploiting nature and like what we
gather from nature um which is
unfortunate because
yeah because i was thinking about this a
few years ago i was like okay well where
does
like where does new wealth come from and
i'm like okay well
new wealth doesn't come from
you know a therapy session like
basically what a therapist provides
is some kind of help for a person who's
in
psychological distress okay so like
services like that don't generate new
wealth
but as i you know as i was like taking
things off the list i think
i think mostly where are
where our wealth comes from like at the
bottom level is what we get
from nature and then uh
the and then and then that can be
made into that can be made into higher
and higher value
things as a result of technology you
know you have techniques innovation like
crafting and sculpting it into something
yeah um
yeah but i do think that we do get most
of our wealth from nature and how we do
that and
how responsibly we do that is important
yeah you know because
because we also like because if we talk
about having a society where everyone
has the same opportunities
well in order to live on the planet that
we have with a certain number of people
only so much can be available to each
person
because like if for instance like we
wanted all of the same things to be
available to people
well if all of like the options
both if all the options in terms of like
places you can go things you can do
like like toys that you can play with
entertainment that you can have
if that was available to everybody well
that would simply not be sustainable
because there
would be just like too much of a burden
on the planet but um we if we can do
this sustainably and go kayaking which
people in nature do like gatherers i'm
sure like we can have leisure activities
for everyone
right and so the question becomes like
okay well maybe
yeah and i think that people can
actually like live a lot like live
very satisfying lives
quite simply and like you can be a part
of a very small community and never
travel too far from where you are and
have a very
rich and fulfilling life um and yeah and
so like
one of the things becomes like okay well
maybe not everyone
in the world has to visit like all 192
countries
before they die or however many it is
like in order to be
like fulfilled and affirmed maybe it's a
lot
like in you so so maybe if we want
everyone to have the same opportunities
maybe those opportunities don't extend
very far out
geographically but but
there doesn't have to be a limit on how
much experiences we have
we can have all the experiences we want
in a more sustainable way that we don't
have to ration it out
right yeah but i just mean in terms of
like in terms of transporting yourself
to different parts of the planet there
are
you know their fuel costs associated
with that
yeah but i don't know if that's
significant enough
that we have to stop doing it i think
there's other things that we can do to
limit
pollution but um
i i love you know
the world that we live in and i love
people i just think that
we don't have the best ability to
express
humanity or love and i think it's
because
like a few people at the top decided to
take everything and
it's like a momentum thing like we got
used to doing that in the feudal ages
and then we're like
let's keep doing that in america and
then we saw communism taken off in
russia and we're like oh [ __ ] that's the
next step we can have more freedom
to everyone else oh so you felt like
communism
was like was an answer to capitalism
which provided a better solution
to various market problems than we had
ever experienced before
uh yeah okay okay so that's one of the
reasons why
like why you favor communism so much is
that to you
it represents like this next possible
step
for humanity yeah okay
and america didn't want to have that
like there's no reason for us to [ __ ]
with the soviet union as much as we did
except that we were afraid of losing our
stronghold okay the people gotcha so
so once it became like once technology
progressed to a point
where a society could have
a kind of controlling influence over the
world
that our like iterations
in developing new ways of structuring
society
to make it better and more free stopped
because
that society namely america which
developed during a time when it could
like
more or less take control of the world
decided that it should stop
yeah i mean it happened with france when
france had their revolution all the
countries in europe were like we can't
have this
let's stomp him like the monarchs were
like
we can't have the next step or else our
people will ask for that
sure of course yeah i think that they're
yeah they're innumerable examples
all across the world in how yeah like in
how there's like
that there's there there's forward
movement and resistance to forward
movement
simultaneously i think there are also a
lot of examples
of oh what was i gonna say
i forget it'll come back to me okay
so uh i mean what do you think about
comedy in austin
it's pretty rocking right now yeah it's
pretty amazing yeah there are like
opportunities to do things every night
of the week no matter who it is that you
are
um i love going to all the mics um yeah
i i would
like to be able to go to more so i'll be
yeah
i love the community it's very different
i think
because of the pandemic we're just
thankful that we have the ability to do
this
and we really enjoy it and we really
enjoy talking to each other because for
the longest time we couldn't
yeah um that's something i can't really
speak to since prior to the pandemic i
didn't i never really did comedy and uh
wasn't a part of like a community like
of open mic comedians however i would
say that i really do
love our community of open micros too
and that the yeah and that everyone is
very supportive
of each other yeah when you go in or
when i go in
to the creek it's like all friends
saying hi to everyone and it's great
because you're not like there
just to make friends you're there to do
comedy
and you can make friends naturally
right which i think is great because
we're coming together and fighting
the billionaire class
[Laughter]
it all comes back to that for you
i like building solidarity i think it's
good that we talk to each other
and i think if we all like were
interconnected it would be a better
world and i like uh
seeing you just being a golden retriever
going up to everyone
wagging your tail thank you
yeah i i i have a great time uh
yeah enjoying yeah enjoying our
community too and that
we have the opportunity to make friends
with a lot of people
and i've been thinking about that
recently and like in
who it is that you're more naturally
attracted to and connected to
and that like because at the moment like
i have
a lot more opportunities to
be friends with and spend time with
people
then you know that i can reasonably take
up and i feel like a consequence of that
is is that like is that the people who
are in our community will have the
opportunity
like to be drawn towards
the ones that they're most interested
in being friends with and like that that
can that can make for some like very
fertile friendships
yeah we have so many options you can
pick the best one
for you yeah well yeah whatever that
happens to be you know or or you can
learn like you know or you can learn
like what's better between multiple
options or
yeah but then i find a difference
between
whose comedy i like and who i can be
friends with
okay and when those align it's great but
usually like some
one that i find really funny it's
awkward because i'm like too respectful
and like oh wow you're so awesome how
interesting
or like someone that i get along with
but isn't funny i'm like
subtly treating like [ __ ] oh yeah
because okay
because you care like because like
because it matters to you whether
they're doing well yeah because when
you're
on stage and you're bombing it's
basically the whole audience gets used
to hating you
and you let them practice hating you oh
interesting
shut the [ __ ] up just having that
thought in your head and then when
you're
off stage you still have that
whoa yeah right well something that i've
seen
like a number of people do which
makes me sad well i saw someone do like
i saw someone say something was i think
i'm gonna
drop a word in his ear next time i see
him but something i've seen a number of
people do
is like go go up and they
either will run out of things that they
had prepared to say
and then just like kind of stay there on
the stage
like and and then or or they just won't
have any plan whatsoever and it's not
going well
and they stay to the very last second of
their time
and like and and you know i've heard a
few of those people say he's like oh
yeah i'm just here for stage time
it's like well you standing on a stage
is not going to make you better
you're practicing bombing you should
practice killing yeah exactly
as i was gonna say is like yeah right
the the habits that you
that you make are the habits that you'll
perpetuate
and yeah yeah so it's like uh
this mentality of some comedians that
are just like i'm just going to do as
much as possible without any thought of
making it
good which is the worst because not only
are they
not getting better but they're also
wasting everyone's time
right and i think that's something that
i actually
make an error on the side of is
um yeah is
is keeping it in my mind that i have to
like go to as many things as possible
and you know and and show up and be
there in this but then sometimes like
i'll
like sometimes i'll be so frantic and
busy in that like the over course of a
few days like oh
i didn't write any new jokes to share
yeah you know and so then i'll need to
write some new jokes and then
yeah so finding a balance between those
things is important
yeah i think the open mics in austin are
pretty
crazy there's a good energy to it
because it's like
matters like joe rogan might be watching
in the back
uh so there's like an importance to it
and there's a weight to it that i think
is
really cool interesting i didn't think
about it in those
terms like because i i wouldn't have
imagined that like someone like joe
rogan would
like would be showing up to a mic but um
yeah i mean of course you have
pre-pandemic comedy experience whereas i
you know basically other than like two
two open mics prior to these
only have post pandemic mic experience
yeah so what made you start the your
the comedy
i just wanted to do it for a long time
um
and in my family i was always like i was
always kind of like the comic relief and
the entertainment like would provide
kind of diffusing like uh like a
diffusing moment for
well like i would provide the diffusion
for a moment of tension
or something in the house um and i was
always
trying to make people laugh like for as
long as i can remember
like i'll say something like and i'll
watch and see if someone laughs
so it's just like a lot of practice in
that area but i've i've always liked to
be in front of people
always liked to be an entertainer did
you move here for comedy
yeah so is there something about the
pandemic like
near-death experience or like oh this is
all finite let me
pursue my dreams no um
uh originally my idea
so so i came back to i came back to
america
in late october 2020. from spain
um yeah from spain and i had
been and i'd been all over europe during
that
previous year and when i was taking that
trip it was
that then that i had decided that what i
really wanted to do was stand up comedy
and i was going to return to america
in new york city and and
start doing the open mic circuit there
because because that was where i
figured was the best place but then of
course you know in the throes of the
pandemic new york city wasn't the best
place
and you know and i've been listening to
the joe rogan experience and you know
and it sounded like
austin was a good spot yeah so just kind
of like in a leap of faith
i came out here on march 30th and things
just took off from there
nice yeah so yeah joe rogan
helped me move here too but it's crazy
how that one man has so much power and
it's like
uh i wish there were more joe rogans but
unfortunately we've only managed to
create one
in our mad capitalist dash for survival
yeah but it's also interesting because
so well how long ago did you move here
uh maybe march or february okay gotcha
yeah so you were just here
a little bit earlier before i was and
before that you were in new york
yeah and after seattle and then l.a
were any of the places during the
pandemic that you were
like like open or free enough to
like to do comedy that you la was okay
l.a was yeah that's good they had a lot
of outdoor mics
seattle only had one or two mics a week
which was very not
enough yeah of course and it's about the
same size as
here so the fact yeah it's way more open
here and
everyone's come here there's a lot more
comedians per
capita here because everyone like
everyone's new here
yeah i mean the creek in the cave has
been has been an enormous influence
on on me and of course it's amazing
it's an amazing like hub for people to
hang out
and like and they've already attracted
like many top comedians there since they
opened on april 1st
yeah todd uh glass everyone
yeah mcfarland joe rogan
tony hinchcliffe so if you come to
austin come to the creek in the cave
everybody
yeah it's a great club have you met
rebecca yeah
okay i used to go to the creek at in new
york right you talked about their their
location
yeah i slept right next to it okay
yeah did mike's three mikes a day there
okay oh so they would do three mics
every day yeah in the basement
and it's two and a half minutes bucket
it's like
40 comedians it's crazy holy cow
some of the best comedy in the world
awesome
i mean even at the moment of open lakes
okay i mean best open mic comedy okay in
the world i think
happened there in that basement that's
freaking awesome yeah
and i lived there just doing mics every
day rebecca was talking about
like doing even more like doing even
more mics at the creek and i was like
that would be amazing but
yeah even like with the 10 that they do
every week i was thinking like that's
banging that's a lot
yeah especially for this scene yeah but
isn't that interesting how like
in a way like okay so the creek in the
cave kind of like becomes
okay one thing that's been going on in
in my mind recently
is realizing how similar
this moment in my life is to
to a time that i became like extremely
involved
in in a particular church and like
christianity in general
and how like and how i was sort of
becoming involved in like what was a
cult
at that point and realizing like how
this moment in my life is similar to
that and like my involvement with
comedy is similar to that yeah it brings
you closer to people
and i think uh the open mic community
is sort of a rare thing it's like a cult
where everyone
can leave anytime they want where we all
chose to be here
we're all chasing something else no one
is
the god i think it's the way a cult is
supposed to be
interesting interesting
yeah you're putting a spin on that that
i wasn't expecting
yeah because people can yeah because the
the
the harmful thing about cults is when
like someone gets thrown out or like
you know or if or if once someone leaves
then they're suddenly
excluded yeah um
and and i think like well but you also
mentioned
uh joe rogan earlier and i do kind of
feel like there
there is a certain subculture
surrounding him which is cult-like
yeah yeah and might not be
the best but he handles it really well
and that he rejects it
he doesn't lean into it too much he just
does his podcast
and tries not to start a cult right
yeah yeah because like he definitely
could if you wanted
yeah that's so that's so interesting um
yeah but this is the best part of being
in a cult
is the uh human
cult or the the village type thing or
community yeah and uh yeah
i think that is one of the best parts of
comedy
is that it forces you to socialize it's
a very social
art form so you can't just do it in your
bedroom like
painting or guitar something that i've
been
wondering lately uh about
comedy is what because like
now that i'm like
neck deep in comedy and like comedy
communities
like i i feel that
like and i'm begin beginning to become
aware
of like the of the social circle
that exists within like within comedy
from the top down like i'm just
beginning to see the bigger picture
but one thing i wonder is whether
what is funny in the world
is partially determined as a result of
like
this network of stand-up comedians like
what they're
yeah we're like a part of a village that
we have the cobbler making shoes and he
makes shoes for the whole village and we
make humor
for the whole village aka the world
oh that's an interesting way of way of
putting it that if
yeah as as the world has expanded and
globalization has taken place and people
are more specialized
in what they do in a sense you have you
have
grand groups of people taking the roles
that a single person might take in a
smaller community
yeah and whoa and that like in that the
comedians like they have this kind of
hive mind like in a sense
and we go out in all intellectual
directions and we're like what is funny
here and then oh look this direction and
then oh
derek is going off in that direction and
there's humor there
so it's like we're pushing the limits
professionally like this is our
full-time job and i think we're
finding humor in things that maybe no
one has discovered yet
true yeah because i have heard an
astonishing number of jokes
since i've gotten to austin yeah some
percentage of which make me laugh
other percentage of which i appreciate
the humor in it and understand
how can you know how how it can be funny
and those ones i usually clap for and
then other ones which like
you know it's like yeah yeah that
you don't pity laugh or don't do it yeah
i mean it's like interesting uh
what people choose to talk about too
like uh
what people are interested in like iuds
everyone loves talking about that
because it's like oh i can have sex
with you and come inside you i know it
blocks the semen
and whatever like it's just interesting
it's like connecting to humanity you get
to
peer inside yeah the tribe the
mind the species you get to peer down
the speculum
but i i do i do like that bit that jesse
has
and he he he has like exactly the kind
of energy
and goofiness yeah yeah yeah
wait wait wait well okay because he has
a thing about iuds so like that the
the worst job in the world has got to be
an iud
because like if you screw it up once
you're done like
you're out of work and then also like
you have
you know like you have like this this
dick coming up to [ __ ] with you and keep
poking you on the head like you know you
there you are
he's like you're not gonna get through
he's like i'm definitely gonna get
through
yeah he's like he's like you better not
come on me man even though
he's just personifying iuds
yeah exactly he's like don't do it don't
oh
man but what if they love it what if
that's what they live for
right it could be well but well well but
i don't think that i
well i mean iuds i mean well like but
it's it has like antagonistic chemicals
to to sperm as like spermicide or copper
or whatever it is that kills yeah
so so like i i think there's got to be
an antagonistic
relationship between the baby and the
personified dick
you know oh yeah or maybe oh yeah maybe
you could like personify him as like
like william wallace you know just like
cutting down
the swath of englishmen in front of him
yeah he's like nothing enough of your
primonocta [ __ ] you know get out of
my wife
yeah that's the worst policy i'm
surprised they named it
they're like let's make this official oh
yeah oh that
doesn't make the colonized population
very friendly to you
right yeah maybe keep that on the dl
right you know just you know get your
rocks off on your own time but
yeah i heard that's like not as
prevalent as we think it is
okay the prima nocta it was like more
for the movie
yeah i am i imagine that's true but it
only has to happen once and everyone's
going to talk about it because that
would really suck right
that would really suck and we're all
like humans like
we're all at the mercy of the uh
things larger than ourselves and we're
pretty much helpless if we're colonized
to fight against it and i think a lot of
these things that we talk about
in terms of like you know in terms of
colonize or like the billionaire class
like i think a lot of those
forces are a lot more are very
impersonal
in that like in that for instance
if it was the irish who were in
a position of strategic advantage
over the english like it would have been
the irish
who were oppressing of the english
probably
unless their culture was such that they
you know that
that they wouldn't do that for some
reason well just because
you're happen to have power over other
people doesn't mean it's going to be
impersonal
you could still make it personal
especially if you have
some artistic flair about you and how
you colonize
oh okay so you feel like that there's
that colonization has artistry to it
yeah i mean everyone likes to think
they're artists why not colonizers they
probably
enjoyed it to some extent or else they
wouldn't have done it
yeah i mean okay well i guess like what
did you enjoy the benefits
i i can i can see enjoying the benefits
of colonizing
because of like well yeah because of the
wealth it can bring you gives you more
options of what you can do and power
over
other creatures slash humans
yeah and people enjoy that so
they could get into that like uh ten
thousand hours of mastery over
[ __ ] other people and torturing them
uh-huh
well yeah i mean why i don't i wonder
like
okay i i wonder how many people like i
wonder
i wonder how enjoyable having power over
others really is
well people jerk off to it like finance
fight
uh stock stock brokers finance bros
they uh they got off on like oh i paid
this guy a hundred bucks so that i could
use his
van and then i've jumped it off a cliff
and
it was his family van but i uh gave him
a thousand or ten thousand dollars
so so this is a trash is [ __ ] oh so so
but that's a a real story that you're
telling yeah some dude told me about it
that new york is bragging about how
morally compromised he was
oh but uh yeah i mean these people find
joy
in uh the power they have because what
else are they gonna do
hmm interesting what do you think causes
that kind of behavior
or attitude uh society that is geared
around that type of mentality
how and how how would you say like our
society is geared around that type of
mentality
uh we have a selfishness greed power
is respected if you have money then you
get to [ __ ] the hottest [ __ ] and then
it's like oh
i have all this power let me use it
and that is what's rewarded in our
society
interesting you don't feel that in the
people you interact with a little
evil uh not much like okay well i would
say that
uh the most that i feel that
and i don't feel it often is
like when i'm is if i'm hanging out with
a mixed group
and like and there are some men
in the group who like try to
put me down in a sliding way in front of
women that they might be interested in
yeah that's that's really pernicious
yeah i mean that that happens
i mean that yeah that happens a lot but
at the same time like i
but there are lots of people that i
don't feel put down
in that way with like with you and riley
and uh and others like so so that's part
of what that's part of
how i make my choices concerning who i
want to spend the most time with
do you want to be a wingman yeah because
because i
i don't want someone like i don't want
someone
in my close social circle who
doesn't want me to be successful or
would despise
some kind of success in my life
because if they're successful i want to
cheer them on
yeah i mean women are very tricky in
that way
they bring up a lot of uh emotions in
people
yeah very primal like yeah i mean for
instance like i i don't really
understand i don't understand
like i don't unders understand logically
the desire to mate
like i understand why
it like i understand an explanation for
why it could exist but
like why would exist is like that's just
like it's what we do it's how we
propagate
but but it's but it it goes way deeper
and further
yeah it's cultural a lot of it like
bonobos
uh well but i think that our culture is
okay yeah so you're bringing up bonobos
but i think the way in which our culture
manifests itself
is partly a result of our biology
and um have you learned have you learned
about like how
uh mammals like a mammal's testicle size
and its mating practices are related
yeah
yeah so we're right in the middle
between chimps and bonobos
or right in the middle between chimps
and gorillas uh
chimps and bonobos are very similar yeah
but bonobos have like a peacemaking
sexual practice whereas you know chimps
are a lot more violent
so that depends on how promiscuous the
females are
and chimps are [ __ ] everyone or
yeah gorillas are not [ __ ] right
anyone but the mail
right exactly yeah the the dominant male
is basically the only one who
but have you read about uh
sex at dawn i have not read that book
and how like in ancient hunter-gatherer
societies they would [ __ ] everyone as a
way to
bridge the gap and maintain unity in the
group
and how like uh fighter pilots in world
war ii would have wife swapping so that
if one of them died
they knew that their wife would be taken
care of
and i don't know like monogamy arose out
of
agriculture which is ten thousand years
old and humans are two hundred thousand
and that's because we needed to pass on
our
possessions since we have possessions
now but back in the day we didn't have
possessions right once you start writing
down contracts
right yeah yeah so i'm
just want to let that sink in but i
don't know what you're saying about uh
what was it like people putting it down
in like a
group mixed group setting and like how
it's our culture is naturally
our sexual practices as a culture it's
naturally whatever
yeah because i think you know i think
our sexual practice as a culture
is defined by by our society and its
history
but also by our biology and like those
yeah those things come in tandem
yeah i just think that our society is
very
wrong about sex and
i'd be willing to i'd be willing to
agree with that
and well like what specifically
yeah what's okay so you've told me some
some about this before what specifically
bothers you about
our approach to sex uh how it has to be
like this soul bonding experience or
like how it
has to mean now you have to take care of
the woman
or the woman now has to be reliant on
you and
how women use sex for survival because
they're cut off from any
economic opportunities to hook someone
in you mean yeah
and it's like this now fraught thing
that's used for survival
instead of to denote love oh instead of
like
recognizing like a mutual bond of
attraction between people
and they can choose to enjoy a sexual
experience together as a result of that
rather than having it be tied to
all of this you know history of
agricultural enterprise
yeah it's not a fine it's now a
financial thing
and like uh responsibility now you're
tied together now
you have to fight for her honor or
whatever which is a nice thing to do i
guess yeah
so so like so what personal experiences
have you had
that um yeah that's not getting
opinions okay well like well surely not
ever but like but yeah just not as much
often yeah not enough love in my life
yeah what other okay so so you said
okay not getting laid and that yeah
that's frustrating of course
um yeah you have to acknowledge
that like that the lifestyle that you've
chosen
living in a van is
like well that's not going to put you
like at the top
of you know
angie's list yeah or whatever uh well i
think that's a problem that
a man has to be able to economically
pay for your dentist or whatever i think
that's
kind of a weird thing but i mean what
does a girl want
she wants to be able to survive an
apocalypse you probably have a better
chance with me
that's probably true so you just have to
wait for the apocalypse
that's the whole thing that i hate
choice is that it's like an economic
thing like you have to be
economically uh part of the game if
you're not part of it then you don't
deserve sex which i think is
a dumb way to do it but i mean i got
into it
because i wasn't getting laden okay oh
you got into the van life because you
weren't getting laid yeah
and it's not just me i mean there are
many personal issues that i could fix
but
it's a lot of men a lot of women not
[ __ ]
yeah uh people that are single that are
desperate not getting laid and people in
bad relationships
because we have this monogamous model
and that creates a lot of tension and
stress in relationships that
cause there to be less sex and
financially
we're just not sexy as men in our
generation because we don't have the
ability to provide
because we have less wealth than the
boomers did at our age
yeah and more wealth inequality yeah i
was recently listening to
an episode of the portal with eric
weinstein and he
was discussing he was discussing sort of
the position that our generation
finds itself in particularly with
respect to
like life after education
um right and he was saying
yeah and i think he was saying that one
of the reasons for
the kind of relative stagnation or
stoppage
in economic growth in recent times
in america is a is a result of like
certain yeah like certain industries not
expanding
as fast as they used to and yeah so i
so i do think that they're
yeah i i do think that there are fewer
like there are definitely fewer
opportunities like when i hear my
grandpa talking about
what it was like to be a young man in
america for him and for his
you know father and grandfather like it
feels like a lot more open and hopeful
place
um but so so i i think that maybe
some of this drought of opportunity
isn't as much
squarely on the shoulders of the
billionaire class that we've been
talking about
as maybe you make it out to seem then
who's to blame
well okay it's so that that's that's a
good question
uh one partial counter to it is like
well maybe there isn't anyone
necessarily to blame
so it's the structure well things to
figure out oh yeah i mean or
or or or maybe like or maybe the way
things that you know
things are arranged like for instance
like we were talking about
we're talking about wealth inequality
like across history
and like uh have have you heard about
that have you heard about like that
poisson distribution being like
that so many things in nature are
distributed like this poisson
distribution whereas 80 20.
yeah exactly yeah we're like yeah it uh
yeah well like yeah i guess it's like 20
of the people or things wind up with 80
of the benefit like or something like
that
yeah i don't think that's a good thing i
think we should try not to have that
type of distribution
yeah well i mean okay so so it's it's
it's probably good
for for us not to have that kind of
distribution all things however
examining how that distribution
manifests itself in nature without human
interference and then
like in human systems i think can give
us insight
into understanding what's going on and
not just seems like a way to be okay
with inequality like this is a very
unnatural inequality that well okay well
if we think about
deer like there's there's one buck who's
going to have
multiple does like that they're they're
like the the the male part
of like the male part of any biological
system
is naturally a higher variance and
lower success rate
part of that system what about bonobos
um i i don't know i don't know like how
many
bonobos the average uh the average male
bonobo sires that would be very
interesting to find out but i bet
they're getting laid a lot more than
bucks that's probably true yeah and so
yeah so so so yeah so what i was
yeah so so it's important to acknowledge
that there
are many different possible
arrangements however i think there
there is always inequality
um yeah i'm not asking to [ __ ] as much
as brad pitt
but i just think that this level of
inequality is
very fixable and unfair okay and now how
do you propose
it it would be fixed economic
redistribution and uh
uh a breaking with the old ways of
thinking about sex
and getting rid of conservative
christians
just throwing them in a pit
well sure yeah i think uh both i only
get this from the contextual things that
you've mentioned
in our conversation i think maybe on
stage but i think just our conversation
that it sounds like
it sounds like uh your early years were
heavily influenced by christianity like
conservative christianity
i guess so yeah mine too um and so i i
can can definitely appreciate what
you're saying there
uh but in terms of so how do you think
that like yeah what what what kind of
economic redistribution
are you in favor of i think the all the
money that goes to the ceos
less of it should go to them and more of
it should go to the workers
uh unions maybe half of the company is
owned by the workers
that work for the company okay uh
yeah unless less uh investors
that are speculating on which companies
going to survive and
shorting stocks and all that [ __ ]
just like rearranging
money to favor themselves yeah
and transferring wealth from the lower
class to the upper class
and i think just like a fair tax
structure
mm-hmm what would be a fair tax
structure
uh like enforcing the laws that
currently exist and making sure they're
not all getting
sent to offshore bank accounts making
sure everyone's paying their fair share
of in companies because like amazon
didn't pay any taxes in 2019 or
something like that
and just like yeah i mean just at least
following the rules that we have and
then if we need to
fix the rules like we had a 90 corporate
tax rate
in the 50s back when america was great
again or whatever
and it didn't mean that we stole 90 of
all the profits it means the companies
were incentivized to invest in the
workers and in public
spaces and not just give all that money
to their investors
yeah that's a good point
but uh you know it's communism so we
can't do it
well yeah okay yeah well i i appreciate
um yeah but i figure like
i figured that i figured that we
as a country could change things
yeah i think if we all are on the same
page
it's just like i think the biggest
stumbling block is the apathy and being
like whatever
just don't think about it just do the
best for yourself it's a waste of time
don't worry about things larger think
only about yourself i feel like there's
a lot of that
which is not helpful yeah
yeah so okay yeah i mean
[Music]
no i agree it's like if if people feel
like if people feel a particular way
about something
they should take like thoughtful and
informed action
about it at the same time like
yeah but at the same time like i i i'm
sometimes cautious
like cautious and taking action because
i want to make sure
like is because because i don't want to
get swept up
in something which is like
which in the end wouldn't be would be
not right to do but which i'm fully
convinced
is the right thing like you know what
cautious
yeah because i i've experienced like i
have experience
of being like of being strongly
persuaded of something
in this case i'm referring to like
christian ideals that i used to hold on
to
and acting in accordance to them uh with
them
and like even like doing so with a lot
of energy and consistency
and then and then realizing that these
are things that
i don't necessarily think are good or
doing good for people
and then having to let go of that so i'm
so yeah luckily now things are so dire
that
can't get much worse oh they could still
get a lot worse
well we're headed there currently so
true anything that fixes it or makes it
faster will only help us in the long run
well that
makes it fall apart faster yeah you
think so
yeah like finish up with america let
some other country take a crack at it
um okay but then what kind of um
like what
but then what kind of uh apocalypse
do you well i think things are so bad
right now
that we need to experiment with
something else
and i think that just letting this go on
is
worse than trying something new and
failing
okay um
yeah i think that we should i mean we
should be trying new things
constantly um but like what are the
indicators to you
that things are at a point like that are
really close to the breaking point
um well there's like the numbers but
then there's like the cultural like
we're not getting along
people are falling apart from reason
they don't even know
what's true anymore that's a topic which
is a lot of interest to me the
polarization that we have been hearing
increasingly about in the media over you
know
over previous years i think like the
first time that i was
exposed to the idea of how like of how
highly polarized
modern american society is wasn't
watching that
tv show the newsroom yeah okay and that
and that
and that initial monologue that
jeff daniels character makes talking
about how america
at that time which i think was around
2010 or so
was more divided than it had been since
the civil war which was a crazy thing to
think about and the fact that it's only
become more divided in the last 10 years
like that does worry me too
however like but but you hear a lot of
people talking about polarization
you hear a lot about and then like the
standard kind of follow-up in that
conversation is like yeah i know we just
need to get along we need to understand
each other but we still haven't learned
how to listen to each other
so i think like a major like so so i
think people have the right thing
in their hearts and they're saying like
and they're saying the right things the
right intention
but the but then but then what's really
necessary is for us to learn
like to listen to each other and uh
to like delay the flare-up of emotion
[Music]
um to like to to see each other
first as people and second as whatever
else
okay yeah i mean it's just hard because
like the other side is so
irrational in my opinion they're not
even arguing from science or
facts they're just want to continue
doing
the primal barbaric experiment they've
done for the past 400 years
and there's no reason besides they want
to maintain power
okay so okay so this part of it we're
talking about
like we're talking about a dichotomy
between your way of thinking
and what we might like ascribe to be the
billionaire classes way of thinking
right yeah conservatives oh okay so you
um all right well
uh well i would say that a lot of the
people
who are most invested in
conservatism aren't really
aren't really financially like
aren't really financially benefited by
it
uh but okay we
okay in that last part of the the
conversation we've entangled
so many things uh i i kind of want to
take a moment to like
to disentangle them um
if we can okay uh
because okay because initially when you
were talking about polarization i
thought you're going to be talking about
polarization between
the left and the right and in a sense
you are but you're talking about
like the fact that you would be defined
as a liberal
based on where you fall broadly
and your is just disagreement
okay so what i would say is that people
who are
okay people who disagree with you
if you want to figure out how to get
along with them
the first thing to focus on is not the
disagreement
it doesn't matter why they disagree with
you
what what matters
okay because i think i think
that most people most
people's basic level yeah i think that
most people
act based upon
feeling much more than upon thinking
um and i and i would even go so far as
to say that
i think that's universally true that
people's
beliefs are informed by their feelings
rather than their you know rather than
their feelings
being informed by their beliefs i think
beliefs are largely a rationalization
for other things
so don't you think most people think
that their beliefs dictate their
feelings
even though their feelings are dictating
their beliefs they
have this idea that it's the other way
around right which makes them even more
irrational but do you feel that your
feelings dictate your beliefs so that
your beliefs dictate your feelings
i feel like my beliefs dictate my
feelings but
who i might be wrong i think that your
feelings dictate your beliefs
yeah i mean that's the right i mean
that's nagging
yeah but the question but right i don't
know if uh
that's true but yeah what about you what
do you think uh
what i think well just before i get to
that i think like one little
polyp of evidence that lives uh that
lives
in the conversation that we've had so
far is like
is you're talking about um like you're
not
like you're talking about uh like not
getting laid very often and that's like
and that's a frustrating state to be in
and
like and so you know
and so a belief could easily spring out
of that
and it should like there's no reason not
to be angry
and be like something's wrong with this
world because i feel bad
we feelings aren't necessarily
irrational interesting
okay yeah that's um
that's interesting because it it used to
be
it used to be my position that
like yeah that something's something's
wrong with this world
uh something's wrong with this world and
as a consequence
well that yeah that something's wrong
with this world because i feel bad
and then my attitude shifted to be like
if i
feel bad in this world how can i figure
out how to get along
in this world without feeling as bad as
i was before
well i can make myself feel better but
then
the world is [ __ ] anyways like it
doesn't change the world and
i don't want to just save myself i want
the whole world
to be better and i don't want to just
like disassociate
from the world just so i can maintain my
mental health i don't
really care about my emotional health
enough
to sacrifice my logic to maintain it
well i'm not talking about
i'm not talking about disassociating
like i don't think that's good for
mental and emotional health
um like as a matter of fact i think
like deeper levels of engagement are
good for mental and emotional health
um yeah but i also see like
but i also see the pain in what you're
saying i recognize it
and yeah i don't think i quite i don't
think i really know
what to say as a reply to that but what
was your question you were going to ask
me a question
uh do you think that your beliefs are
feeling based or if your feelings are
thought based
i think that my yeah i think that my
beliefs arise
as a result of my feelings um
and i'll give you let's see if i can
come up with
an example for that in my present
context because there aren't too many
things which i identify
it presently as being strong beliefs
that i hold
in large part because of the situation
that i
i mentioned where i suddenly realized
that i had all these beliefs which
you know yeah which were yeah
which which were delusional um
i'd say
okay
well um
i'm trying to think of like what my like
what my
main feelings and okay
uh what what like what the main feelings
i'm experiencing
in life are i did think of one example
like and and and and that and that
example was that
like for instance you know i've been
separated from for my girlfriend
like geographically for a long time now
it's been let's see it's coming to the
end of may we
last saw each other at the end of
october it's like seven months and we're
not going to see each other for another
two months
two more months yeah and so like so nine
months being apart
is quite difficult you know and and
being faithful to a relationship like
that so like for me like so so i i just
i just didn't want to mention this
because it's also on the subject of sex
but
you know like being faithful to a
relationship that you're nine months
separated from
is very difficult and so i brought up
like a number of times
the like the possibility is like you
know do you think that
like that we should be allowed to you
know like to
you know to enjoy like the company of
other people
like while we're apart for so long and
you know
and that is like and and that i feel
like was a belief which was
like which was informed by my feeling
of like you know feelings of frustration
so yeah i mean you're very emotional
i mean i think you feel very strongly
and i don't think there's anything wrong
with
feeling i mean it's like the
subconscious brain is pretty smart
and uh just because it's a feeling
doesn't mean necessarily that it's wrong
but then if you
make that feeling like oh i hate
mexicans
when you're actually just economically
impoverished
and you want a better life for yourself
and your family and you feel
that you're responsible for
where that feeling leads you to think
yeah and i think it's yeah and i think
it's very very important to
like to to focus on for each person to
focus on what it is that they can do
to make their and the world's condition
better
uh through their action um
and uh yeah so i
yeah rather than you know rather than
formulating
irrational beliefs but uh
don't you think it's rational to want
workers to have more of their
pay yeah sure no i yeah i
um yeah no i think that
uh okay any hesitance that you find
is a result of like i don't like to
answer to questions that i don't have
have evidence
for but i think yeah i i think that
people who
who who trade a significant portion of
their lives
uh their time and their energy to a job
uh to a job for an organization should
be fully supported by that organization
um you know yeah i mean
i don't know maybe uh maybe
some of my feelings are extreme
uh but uh yeah i mean i don't know i
think like
religion is like a way that the state
and the powers that be kind of
infiltrate our mind and put a back door
into it and
[ __ ] around and mess it up and now
like we don't have faith in our
convictions or something like that
i think i don't think that's all that
religion does but i do agree with you
that that religion has played that role
many times in many places
but then also well i actually have have
kind of
have a my
opinion on this topic changed somewhat
while i was abroad
and i i went to go see
a friday night service in westminster
cathedral
and that opened my eyes to
the way that the church of england works
which
because it is part of the state that the
church and the state
meet in the crown the queen yeah i think
that that's
that's a better arrangement for religion
in a country
than the one that then the completely
separate one that we have
in the united states because
when i when i listened to the sermon it
became
clear to me that because the church and
the state
are bound together in england that
political matters
must influence like must
affect the church as well as like
scientific discovery that the church
suddenly has to be
like has to be ign fully acknowledging
and present
to secular discovery like you know
scientific discovery and then also
political realities
as a result the church has to actually
be grounded more in reality
than churches in america which can
divert and
yeah and uh as you say disassociate
like as as far from reality as they want
to yeah
and you could and you could wind up
believing as i did at a time
things which are so unbelievably
far-fetched that like
that that dispel them out on paper and
ink like
you would not recognize them as earth as
we know it
yeah that's interesting so it's like it
grounds the church in reality and makes
it more
right more practical yeah that's good
i think it's disturbing to have that
much of uh
politics and the official governing body
be the subconscious
uh thing that's like basically your
instincts or
i don't know whatever the church is like
i don't know it's like irrational
so but i mean a lot of humanity is
irrational i just don't know if that
type of thinking is
ready for the 21st century but yeah i
mean the church
until now it was useful okay the church
may be irrational but i think a lot of
those ancient stories like
they the reason why they're so ancient
they get retold over and over is that
they
is that they strike on some like on some
human universals
um but earlier you were saying about now
[ __ ] i forgot again it doesn't matter
yeah
yeah i mean i think it's a good way i
think it's better than trying to be
rational all the time
i think if you try to be rational all
the time then you go crazy but if you're
like oh some things are just irrational
and we believe it because we do then it
takes out a lot of
work which i think was very important
back in the day but i think now with our
super computers and
all the people we have i don't know if
it's as necessary
but i mean i think that we could do with
a little more
spirituality in our world right isn't
that funny how yeah superstition makes
you totally cr
makes you crazy if you totally invest in
that rationality it does the same
it seems like you need some kind of
blend blending of the two like you need
a spirit of computers
yeah like you you need uh yeah like a
spiritual
i mean i i wonder if maybe that's like
maybe that's related to the
like related to the fusion of quantum
and newtonian physics
like because one like because quantum
physics definitely has a more
spiritual quality to it it being so
baffling yeah
and you know newtonian physics is is
like you know is
is one of is one of the main fruits of
rationality
you know yeah so
you want to call it a day sure yeah we
can wrap up here
all right thank you so much for doing it
yeah it's been a pleasure thanks for uh
thanks for having me hans yeah
we discovered and we solved things i
feel like
yeah well definitely we got to know each
other better
which i think is the is the biggest
payout for me
so what one thing i i like i like
talking to you when we get on these
subjects is you're very
you're very in earnest and uh
and honest conversation is is i think
one of the best ways to like get to know
what a person is about
because there's a lot of fakery out in
the world and you're not it
thank you derek yeah thank you hans
enjoyed it very much
yeah thank you listeners bye